welcome back to sunday night in america
president zielinski delivered a powerful
message to congress this week and once
again implored the u.s
to do more he told american lawmakers he
needs a no-fly zone and additional
defense systems hours later
president biden announced the u.s would
send an additional 800 million dollars
in defense aid including stinger
missiles and drones and firearms
no doubt it will be helpful but is it
enough and should the world's greatest
superpower be doing even more
joining us now is the house republican
leader from california congressman kevin
mccarthy congressman
thank you for joining us you you were in
the room for that speech tell us your
reaction and the reaction of the other
members of congress
well thank you trade dre i can just
first i do want to take one moment to
honor the memory and life of don young
the dean of the house i know you worked
closely with him he represented alaska
for about three quarters of time they've
been a state
he was a giant of a man but a heart
bigger in the capital
so
yes
zielinski spoke to us in a ha in the
house it was the was the house the
senate republicans and democrats alike
you know what he did saying what he did
not say what he did say was to help us
and he weaved in
um
he weaved in themes of america from 911
to pearl harbor to martin luther king it
was a moving it was a very moving talk
but he never asked to send american men
and women into war all he asked was
allow us to have the weapons defend
ourselves and this is where president
biden has continued to make a mistake it
wasn't just how he pulled out of
afghanistan it wasn't that he said in a
press conference president biden that
they've if putin took a little of
ukraine it would be okay he was too slow
in providing the weapons so ukraine can
defend himself and what biden also did
was hold up the mig's planes from poland
so ukraine can create their own no-fly
zone why deny them that it's no
different than sending them a stinger or
any other weaponry allow them to defend
themselves and fight for freedom i would
believe in the house and in the senate
there is bipartisan support to allow the
polish mig airplanes to go to ukraine
so ukraine can create a no-fly zone
themselves
you know kevin we just saw the images
and they're powerful images i mean look
you're serving in a tough time where
bipartisanship is hard to come by but it
certainly looked like that was a
bipartisan reaction it so is there a
desire on both sides of the aisle to do
even more and are the democrats
communicating that to
president biden
i know some democrats are and inside
that room
one place that was so powerful zielinski
asked us all to watch a video in this
video you could see it's almost started
out like a chamber of commerce the
beautiful cities of ukraine
then they put
modern day
video of weaponry coming in from russia
killing maternity wards the children the
horrific signs of bombing a theater as
we watched afterwards that was that was
clearly marked this was for children and
there wasn't a dry eye in the room after
that but i think there's a bipartisan
support to supply the weapons to ukraine
to defend themselves the difficulty here
is that biden has waited so long the
supply chain is not just there yet the
routes to get it to the locations and
it's all throughout ukraine you've
already had millions of people who had
to leave ukraine you've had thousands of
people who have been killed horrifically
of what putin is doing and his plan is
to even go further if he had taken
action sooner maybe putin would not have
entered ukraine but we need to supply
them the weapons to defend themselves
yeah kevin you're there and i am not it
almost appears as if the by
administration was a little you know
invested in diplomacy for a little bit
too long i mean when you got troops
massing at your border i'm not sure
diplomacy is what you need as much as
military aid
we got about 30 seconds you may be the
speaker of the house when this is still
going on
what would you say to biden you're the
speaker of the house what would you say
to him in terms of helping ukraine
you know at this moment in time it's
really the actions you've taken before i
would continue to help ukraine but i
would take a different action going
forward i would look to taiwan don't
make the same mistake twice do not let
china become stronger in their ability
to take taiwan sell taiwan the weapons
to defend themselves so america is not
getting asked the question to go into
war
work
peace through strength we have seen time
and again works in this world when you
have ukraine who wants to defend
themselves don't have them fight with
sticks give them the weapons and they
could be able to win to deter putin from
ever moving forward and bring the rest
of the world together against putin for
this horrific actions and the murders
that he is taking place right now
kevin mccarthy the minority leader for
the republicans in the house from the
great state of california thank you for
joining us on a sunday night my best to
your family hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else